So data doesn't leave the source computer
unless it gets a signal that there's enough bandwidth
for it to travel on.
In the early days of the Internet,
when operating costs were really high
and it was really important not to lose any data,
then the system was set up for interactions
to activate the flow of data.
It's interesting that the ants are using an algorithm
that's so similar to the one that we recently invented,
but this is only one of a handful of ant algorithms
that we know about,
and ants have had 130 million years
to evolve a lot of good ones,
and I think it's very likely
that some of the other 12,000 species
are going to have interesting algorithms
for data networks
that we haven't even thought of yet.
So what happens when operating costs are low?
Operating costs are low in the tropics,
because it's very humid, and it's easy for the ants
to be outside walking around.
But the ants are so abundant
and diverse in the tropics
that there's a lot of competition.
Whatever resource one species is using,
another species is likely to be using that
at the same time.
So in this environment, interactions are used
in the opposite way.
The system keeps going
unless something negative happens,
and one species that I study makes circuits
in the trees of foraging ants
going from the nest to a food source and back,
just round and round,
unless something negative happens,
like an interaction
with ants of another species.
So here's an example of ant security.
In the middle, there's an ant
plugging the nest entrance with its head
in response to interactions with another species.
Those are the little ones running around
with their abdomens up in the air.
But as soon as the threat is passed,
the entrance is open again,
and maybe there are situations
in computer security
where operating costs are low enough
that we could just block access temporarily
in response to an immediate threat,
and then open it again,
instead of trying to build
a permanent firewall or fortress.
So another environmental challenge
that all systems have to deal with
is resources, finding and collecting them.
And to do this, ants solve the problem
of collective search,
and this is a problem that's of great interest
right now in robotics,
because we've understood that,
rather than sending a single,
sophisticated, expensive robot out
to explore another planet
or to search a burning building,
that instead, it may be more effective
to get a group of cheaper robots
exchanging only minimal information,
and that's the way that ants do it.
So the invasive Argentine ant
makes expandable search networks.
They're good at dealing with the main problem
of collective search,
which is the trade-off between
searching very thoroughly
and covering a lot of ground.
And what they do is,
when there are many ants in a small space,
then each one can search very thoroughly
because there will be another ant nearby
searching over there,
but when there are a few ants
in a large space,
then they need to stretch out their paths
to cover more ground.
I think they use interactions to assess density,
so when they're really crowded,
they meet more often,
and they search more thoroughly.
Different ant species must use different algorithms,
because they've evolved to deal with
different resources,
and it could be really useful to know about this,
and so we recently asked ants
to solve the collective search problem
in the extreme environment
of microgravity
in the International Space Station.
When I first saw this picture, I thought,
Oh no, they've mounted the habitat vertically,
but then I realized that, of course, it doesn't matter.
So the idea here is that the ants
are working so hard to hang on
to the wall or the floor or whatever you call it
that they're less likely to interact,
and so the relationship between
how crowded they are and how often they meet
would be messed up.
We're still analyzing the data.
I don't have the results yet.
But it would be interesting to know
how other species solve this problem
in different environments on Earth,
and so we're setting up a program
to encourage kids around the world
to try this experiment with different species.
It's very simple.
It can be done with cheap materials.
And that way, we could make a global map
of ant collective search algorithms.
And I think it's pretty likely that the invasive species,
the ones that come into our buildings,
are going to be really good at this,
because they're in your kitchen
because they're really good at finding food and water.
So the most familiar resource for ants
is a picnic,
and this is a clustered resource.
When there's one piece of fruit,
there's likely to be another piece of fruit nearby,
and the ants that specialize on clustered resources
use interactions for recruitment.
So when one ant meets another,
or when it meets a chemical deposited
on the ground by another,
then it changes direction to follow
in the direction of the interaction,
and that's how you get the trail of ants
sharing your picnic.
Now this is a place where I think we might be able
to learn something from ants about cancer.
I mean, first, it's obvious that we could do a lot
to prevent cancer
by not allowing people to spread around
or sell the toxins that promote
the evolution of cancer in our bodies,
but I don't think the ants can help us much with this
because ants never poison their own colonies.
But we might be able to learn something from ants
about treating cancer.
There are many different kinds of cancer.
Each one originates in a particular part of the body,
and then some kinds of cancer will spread
or metastasize to particular other tissues
where they must be getting resources that they need.
So if you think from the perspective
of early metastatic cancer cells
as they're out searching around
for the resources that they need,
if those resources are clustered,
they're likely to use interactions for recruitment,
and if we can figure out how cancer cells are recruiting,
then maybe we could set traps
to catch them before they become established.
So ants are using interactions in different ways
in a huge variety of environments,
and we could learn from this
about other systems that operate
without central control.
Using only simple interactions,
ant colonies have been performing
amazing feats for more than 130 million years.
We have a lot to learn from them.
Thank you.
(Applause)